[Music]
hey baby we going to be here all day we
going to be here all day baby I like
this kind of party welcome back to the
way back I'm Ryan sickler over here Ryan
sikler Ryan sickler on all social media
very excited to have on the way back in
the seat today ladies and gentlemen the
machine ber crer here trigger warning
trigger warning you will find tobacco in
your life again listen to where we're
going today trigger warning if you're
trying to quit smoking dipping chewing
pouches whatever you got don't don't
listen to this don't listen to this so
you said Tom got you addicted is that
Tom got me back addicted back addicted
to it but when did you first start I'll
tell you and then you you go first and
I'll fresman year freshman year Russell
Matthews me Alan rer Blake Casper Cayman
lazara I think maybe Jay Langford we
were walking in South Tampa in one of
the most beautiful neighborhoods you
could ever walk in I miss Sal Tampa if I
if if I could I'd live there and Russell
Matthews pulled out a can of
Hawkins and he said do you want to take
a dip and I said no I don't want to
throw up and he goes no no no no this
isn't bad you should try it and I
felt I felt my first chest hair come out
I put in a dip of Hawkin and we walked
and it kicked in and we talked and we
walked to the golf course and we took it
out and I
was hooked I was hooked and I was it was
the first that you know Pinocchio had
the donkey boys that was my first walk
into the donkey Boys I Tried a cigarette
after that [__] loved cigarettes I
wasn't even doing it right they taught
me how to inhale loved a cigarette had
you had a drink before
that no you did tobacco before anything
that was your first before anything yeah
first substance and then and then I
would get cigarettes and we would walk
around our neighborhood and [__]
smoke cigarettes and [__] it was so
fun the smell of a cigarette when a the
first draw of a cigarette dude is so
sexy still the first strike when that
tobacco when the before it's smoked and
everything's coming out of it that first
light of a cigarette smells so [__]
good my dad gave me dip I'm telling you
in elementary school bro I'm telling you
my father gave us the and here he he
went hard on it too I saw him one day
just out there popping and he didn't do
it a lot he just had he's like Ryan I'm
not going to live forever we need to get
you into everything real quick he didn't
even live
long we don't know this right now but we
only got 12 years left so let's get
let's get we it's going to be a little a
little bit of a quick
Court crash court let me see your dick
pull it out all right so he gives me
Hawking gives us Hawking and teaches us
you know put a little in your lip or
whatever right cuz he would hunt back in
the day and stuff we were never into
hunting once we found Sports he was like
done I think he just went hunting with
his buddies to just to do something you
know what I mean once we were in sports
he was like I don't give a [__] about
hunting but put it in and I'm like this
shit's kind I got a buzz I really got
like it's a it's a cool buzz you it's a
cool buzz and I start getting into it
but I'm talking this this is just a few
months of this and then next thing I
know I'm putting a skull Bandit all
right so now I got a Hawking in my lip
and I got a bandit in the side okay I'm
in elementary school okay I'm in like
fourth or fifth grade the most Baltimore
thing in the [__]
world and then I swallow it oh and I get
shout out to Ty
Rodriguez and I remember with tgz I get
so [__] sick dude so sick and I'm
like Dad I'm throwing up and he is
laughing so hard I'm like why would you
give this to a kid and he's like that's
why that's why I go what do you mean he
goes you're either going to love it or
you're going to hate it from now on and
Kirsten said it earlier when you pop
that winter green to this day you see
how you are I'm the opposite I am
nauseous as [__] when I smell that and
I've watched my friends Swig
accidentally off their Snapple bottle of
spit and [__] you know like ah but I he
my dad told me he said he watched his
uncle and this was back cuz I remember
when you could walk into like little
convenience store we had little Georges
and all these little stores and you
could get Beach Nut like real tobacco
red man so Beach that old school Beach
Nut right there Beach Nut was the [__]
but my dad said he watched his uncle
have a fall asleep in a recliner and
then he just heard and he swallowed it
and he said he just [__] and puked and
he's like that's so I never saw my dad
do it again after that either I was like
what the [__] that all about so let's
I'm going to I'm going to I want to are
there they are there's that band paint
I'm going to paint F maybe five pictures
of my memories of tobacco and these are
beautiful is that one with Russell
Matthews with Haw with Hawkins and then
I was a casual user I would if the guys
were doing it and cigarettes in the back
of Trey Arnold's car driving around
freshman sophomore year smoking a
cigarette in the back of that car anyone
want a cigarette yeah [__] yeah and you
smoke a cigarette and to be in a car
with a bunch of bros driving around
talking [__] smoking cigarettes was
[__] beautiful then uh at Allen
rieger's beach house uh Scott O'Brien
got me to try
Copenhagen and and I was like I was like
I was like okay it was the snuff snuff
it was it was not pouches it was snuff
and you check the date on it I was like
all the fun [__] it what's the date on
your Copenhagen and they' tell you and
be like it's going to be dry uh and then
you started getting into it then we go
to baseball and Coach Kent would let us
dip while we played while we not during
the games but like he was our coach for
our Legion ball and he' he'd have a can
and he'd be like boys and we had
teachers at school shout out to coach
Scio who would be like you got a can on
you and you'd be like yeah and he'd take
a dip out of your can he take some of
your dip out of your
can yeah and and then and then oh [__]
man I missed that the smell of that so I
will buy buy cans of Co I will never dip
again but I will buy cans of Copenhagen
and cans of skull mint so we then go to
college and copenhagen's around there's
two types of dudes there's dudes who dip
skull and dudes who dip Copenhagen and
my guys were the guys the people I hung
out with skull mint and [__] I
started dipping skull mint and then
skull came out with flavors in my
probably first junior year or third
sophomore year it came out they came out
with flavors Cherry oh and I
remember that summer when they came out
with flavors trying them all I [__] I
loved them I loved them see I never got
into this cuz of that oh and and and
cigarettes and skull there was no better
feeling than going into my fraternity
house and for and everyone's in the
lounge and we're all talking [__]
busting balls the funniest dudes I've
ever known in my life were in that
fraternity house I remember Jason phino
Shout Jason flamino he was jacked as
[__] everyone was sitting there and he's
like and so and someone goes Jason how
come your arms aren't as big as your or
your your legs aren't as big as your
arms and he goes yeah I don't know and
Damen berck goes well you should start
sticking the needle in your ass and and
and everyone's like yo I need to dip
right now that energy of like we're
gonna light up Jason F Amino I remember
Eddie Fernandez Eddie Fernandez put his
dog down right he had hold on he put his
dog this is the [__] hardest I've
ever laughed Eddie Eddie Fernandez put
his dog down and he was in chapter and
we're like where's chewy and he goes
chew is a house dog and this is a
different time okay they would it was a
black it was it was a black lab resc it
was not a good-look dog and it was and
it had ticks and it was weird and the
the dudes no one knew who did it but
someone would take the jock from the
pool table the white chalk and put a
line down chew's back so he looked like
a
skunk
and Eddie would get so [__] pissed so
one day Eddie puts chewy down he goes
comes into the chapter it's [__] 180
dudes right 180 dudes and Eddie comes in
the chapter and someone goes where's
chewy and he goes well I put her down I
put her down because the way you guys
treated chewy he didn't deserve that
chew was a great [__] dog and we're
all like [__] and Jason filamin was
Eddie's roommate he goes Eddie
I I got to tell you
man I was responsible for the skunk line
a lot of times like we just thought it
was funny and you know if you for any
reason if I had anything to do with the
reason you put chewy down thank
[Music]
you and the room lit up chewy for an
hour they're like that dog sucks so bad
spitting a week later chewy shows the
[__] back up no this [__] never
killed his goddamn dog he never killed
his [__] dog and then chewy showed up
and chewy was like guys but because we
had trashed chewy so hard we ended up
loving
chewy CU Chewy was like JY was one of us
now and but I remember that as soon as
that everyone's like I need a dip I need
a dip right
now and then and then and then this is
about tobacco this is about tobacco so
then I I go to Europe I smoke so much in
Europe that I I end up not enjoying it
anymore and I go home I said I'm done
all tobacco I'm done uh tobacco and all
of it and then I go to One softball
intermal softball game and I put a dip
in and immediately I was I've never felt
addiction that way I went in and I felt
it kick in and I was like God damn it
I'm [__] back I'm back on dip I can't
[__] believe it I moved to New York
and I can't find dip and I don't want to
smoke so I quit I quit all together a
second I moved to New York I never did
it again and I move out to
LA and my dad sends me some cigars and I
I had had cigars before but I saw it to
be this High fluen thing that I didn't
want to be a part of I opened the French
doors I lived in cile B de Mill's old
house I opened the French doors
overlooking Hollywood and Highland and I
had a cigar by myself in the house in
smoking inside a cigar inside is so much
sexier than outside in my opinion and I
had a cigar and the nicotine from the
cigar kicked in and I felt a little bit
and I enjoyed a cigar and from that
moment to this day I have enjoyed cigars
effortlessly I love them so much because
it allows me I think it brings my blood
pressure down I've really started
smoking cigars now cut two I'm not
drinking I'm in La I drive to the Right
Aid on the corner of Fairfax and
Sunset and
I just started I just met to The Griddle
bro yeah right next to the griddle and I
said and I was like H I said you know
what I wouldn't mind I wouldn't mind
some red man I had had red man in a
while and I was like you actually would
chew back in the day too oh yeah well I
never did that we did all of it in all
of high school put a big Chaw in yeah
and and and I did you ever do the plug
remember the one that had the pl of
course of of
course
bring up tobacco with the plug that that
a plug of
tobacco I never got into that I would
see it all the time and I'd see dudes do
it I'm like you're a different type of
dude you're using a plug plug and they
had Red Man totems you cut it off right
there see that oh was so sexy it just
fall apart in your mouth you had to
you'd have to work it You' get it in
your cheek and you have to work it it up
and it find its
integrity in your [__] mouth Levi
Garrett's really great but uh Red Man
totems were awesome they were this long
and it was a stick a plug stick that's
it that's the one I'm thinking R man
totems and and so I'm in New York I'm in
La I haven't [__] with tobacco in
probably in probably seven years six
years and I put in a chew and
immediately I'm back immediately I'm
going I'm not going to dip I don't want
to dip but I'm going to start chewing
and Leanne's dad has chewed
almost twice a day his entire [__]
life I meet Le what's he doing red red
maned golden blend golden blend [__]
it's good [__] Red Man gold blend is
so [__] good and I was working I was
working with Jay Moore at the time Jay
used to dip I didn't want to dip because
I knew I thought dip was the next level
I've always held dip at this like I'm
really respectful of not dipping because
I know that once I dip I'm gone forever
and so I I start chewing Red Man golden
blend and Leanne's
dad uh when when she when we went home
for the first time she she was like I'm
really embarrassed I I'm not sure how
you're going to fit in with my family I
was like what do you mean she's like
well you know we don't have money and I
was like I'm I'm fine she goes no no I
mean like we're you know we're very
modest and I was like oh that's fine
she's like We're going to stay with my
dad and I was like cool she goes well my
dad lives in a convenience store I was
like what she was like he owns a
convenience store he lives in the back
so so we're going to be living in a
convenience store for like a week and
part of me is like okay like I I didn't
know how I was going to you know fit in
first of all the convenience store was
attached to the freezer so it was Ice
[__] cold there were zero windows and
he had the best [__] couch in the
world second I got in there the first
night I was like I could live in a
convenience store for the rest of my
life then I wake up and everything in a
communion store you can just eat you
could just eat anything there's beer
I'm just sitting and dring and eating in
a conveni store all fcking day and her
dad gets the hook up on Golden blend so
her dad starts hooking me up a golden
blend and I am [__] in it I am
chewing to the point we work I worked
with J Moore what are you spitting in
chut can you ever the choc nuts all the
guys would have a choc nuts can a whole
coffee can put a put a piece of paper in
it and then whatever cup I have was my
spit cup and I remember at my lowest of
tobacco I was working with J Moore we
were in Brea and I walked from the Brea
Improv to the grocery store behind the
strip mall but I walked all the way
trying to get chew cuz I needed chew I
was addicted I was really [__]
addicted and I went everywhere to get
chew and I couldn't find it and I was
like a [__] I have a problem Leanne gets
pregnant we go to our wedding [__]
chew like crazy cuz in the South we're
driving in a car to go to our honeymoon
we went down to a place called Little
Palm Island could not afford it still
probably can't afford it it's so [__]
expensive we didn't know how much it
cost it we blew so much [__] money
there in the car I put in a chew lean's
pregnant at time secret time uh and I
realize this is not going to end well
I'm like I'm going to get mouth cancer I
just I have a baby girl on the way I am
not I'm done and I quit chewing tobacco
that week I never chewed again I never
chewed ever again I started smoking
cigars every now and then I'd have
cigars no dip no chew no nothing and
then this soon to be fat [__]
again Tom
sigura says to me have you had uh Rogues
I go what the [__] Rogue and he goes
dude they're
awesome and I'd seen like all the bus
with the boys guys did it all the
[__] all the bar stool guys all put
zins in their mouth Shane Gillis eats
them like Tic Tacs and I'm like [__] man
I've i' I've wanted to flirt with them
so for so long I've been I've been
flirting with zins I'd buy zins I'd buy
cans and smell it it would remind me of
my pledge ship of being a pledge and I I
buy a can of copen and I put my tongue
and I put my tongue in it and taste it
and then I spit it out
dude you'd buy a whole can just lick it
a little bit and then throw it out we
drove Georgia to college and I bought
cans of Copenhagen and licked them and
licked them lick them lick them smell
them smell them and it would bring me
back to being it would bring me back to
isn't it crazy Nostalgia the way smell
just ties to Memories like that it's
it's insane music too David Allen Co
with a can of
Copenhagen and I learned how to drink
over the Copenhagen so I could drink and
chew and swallow it and [__] coach Kent
said you know real men swallow it real
men don't spit and I was like okay so I
started doing that that's not good for
you dude I remember so the older times
right like yeah tell me if you had any
of this our little league baseball coach
smoked oh right in our face like I talk
about he would lean over you and show
you how to bunt with a cigarette and and
your your eyes are burning and he's like
why aren't you getting down like cuz
your [__] cigarettes burning the [__]
out of my eye alen rer mom smoke right
in our face alen riger's mom would drive
us to the beach and smoke with the
windows up like dude I flew to Europe I
flew to Europe with my buddy wio and and
we picked smoking section on the plane
they had a smoking section you have
never realized how little you smoke
until you sit around smokers on a
[__] plane both of us are throwing up
like this is disgusting the whole plane
is a smoking section when someone's
smoking on it it was I have not uh
smoked a cigarette in so was
20 probably two when I went to Europe so
in roughly 30 years I've not smoked a
cigarette I didn't I haven't taken a dip
in 30 years 30 years I have smoked
cigars I enjoy I love cigars I love
cigars I love everything about cigars I
love the history of the cigars I love
everything about cigars and when
I quit drinking for this big chunk
cigars were my go-to joint in a cigar a
joint in a cigar and I mean I [__]
tatah cigar a nice big bold cigar joint
and then a cigar in the back porch was
my every night and I said said I got to
stop on these cigars the day we went to
my cruise we were in Miami and Ryan the
same little addiction thing came out and
I was like we got there we landed and
off the plane I didn't drink on the
plane and I was like I was like I need
to I want to hit a VAP pen and I want to
have a cigar let's go to a cigar lounge
and we went into a cigar lounge and sat
with these men that all sit in smoking
cigars Leanne came lean was like oh but
had the best [__] conversation best
[__] conversation and had a Scar and
I felt the kick of the the nicotine when
you get towards like halfway through you
feel it almost and I was like God damn
it I [__] love scars but I's like I
got to quit smoking cigars CU I'm
smoking them every [__] day I'm
smoking sometimes two a day I get I have
one full cigar full [__] cigar I when
I saw you yeah that's a fat one out
there he had and I said I gotta I got to
quit the cigars because I would be like
I would we would go to Austin how long's
it take you to smoke a full cigar like
that like 45 minutes are you doing it in
one session or you cut it and come no no
no no I'm and by the way shout out to
Ron Bennington I remember one time
talking to him about cigars and he said
I have more cigars than I'll ever
[__] smoke I I'll never get through
all the cigars that I have and he goes
if I don't like it I'll just I'll just
[__] have a new one and so I started
going like I have so many [__] cigars
cuz people send me cigars cigar
manufacturers reach out to me like tatah
uh uh uh uh I name them all right now
but they will send me boxes so I have
boxes and boxes of cigars so if I didn't
like a cigar I'd start it maybe I'd have
a cup of coffee few
smoke a little bit of the cigar put the
cigar on be like [__] I'm done with it
but I said to myself I got to quit
cigars because I'm smoking too many of
them and then that soon Tobe fat [__]
introduced me to zins and I will tell
you I will tell
you the second so we did Rogues I didn't
really the Rogues didn't kick as much
they were fine they were fine we were
dabbling in Rogues and then we got a can
of zins I gotten high after show I'm not
really drinking much after my shows
these days at all really and I got high
and I put his Zin in and my finger
started tingling all of it came back all
of it came back does taste like the old
doesn't it's just it just tastes a
little winter green the nicotine it is
so beautiful Ken bring up um Hawkin
that's yeah hawkin's the gateway drug
it's the finger in the
[__] if you're looking to [__] Hawkins
the finger in the [__]
skull mint is neck kissing but [__]
Copenhagen is anal sex it is so
good so good cigar is more like just
like flirting and texting in my opinion
and I'll tell you right now these zins
there's maybe and and Peter's as
addicted as I am because I got him
addicted because I got addicted I was
like I'm not going into this alone I
said I said listen it's not bad for us
if we just do it for a short period so
we're quitting January 1st we're
quitting okay but we we've i' I put it
online I was like how many zins are too
many zins cuz we're 6 milligrams is the
ones we're doing and I've a cup of
coffee and a Zen and you are so [__]
creative you are so dialed in you are so
it's a buzz it's and I gota be honest
with you I think sometimes I don't drink
because I want to have a Zen I had a
buddy one time he uh his brother had
sent them some Cubans from Florida and
um also some rum but the rum broke in
the package and soaked the cigars so he
let them dry Sun Dry he was like let's
just try them let me tell you something
bur rer I got so [__] up smoking a rum
soaked cigar I got [__] I had to put
it out I was like I'm [__] up I they
uh Brothers happy accident black dudes
love my dad there's a they love you CL
Brothers black dudes black men black men
love a little bit of conac in their in
their humidor and to let it seep into
the cigars oh is that right that's
that's brand new stereotype
uh but I've only known two black guys to
do it but I've never known anyone else
to do it other than these black dudes
and so and and those cigars [__] kick
they [__] awesome dude I I I mean I
get nostalgic I just did a show in
Winston Salem and I was like oh big
tobacco baby let's go look at their
houses like I want to [__] well
remember NASCAR used to have skull
Bandits and Winston it was the Winston
Cup for they got rid of tobacco out of
the whole thing yeah used to be a skull
guy riding around out there and [__]
it's the coolest conversations I
remember Bill bur would call me out and
be like yo you want to have a cigar and
just come over have a cigar and just
chop it up no booze just smoking cigars
it's the coolest [__] thing you can
do as a man is have a cigar with another
man I've done it with Tommy so many
times like his neighbor is a big cigar
guy and so I remember one of the first
times I was in Austin we went up to his
house went up to his porch and had cigar
is just talking [__] and I [__] love
it I love that Rogan smokes cigars now
because it's so it's so not I mean I I I
I just say this but it's so something I
never thought Joe would do I never
thought he was just not a cigar guy and
I remember the first time I went in Jo
was like you want a cigar and I was like
[__] thank you Lord if this dude
could not get cooler this guy is the
epitome of like for us he's the man he's
the [__] bro he is he is the most
loving sensitive coolest thoughtful dude
in the world but when he started smoking
cigars I was like [__] yeah this is what
I've wanted is to [__] have a cigar
with Joe and every time you do his
podcast cigar whiskey [__] yeah
oh I love it I love I love everything
tobacco's given me and I understand that
I can't do it all the time I understand
there's a finite time limit I will quit
zins January 1st but I'll start up again
one time cuz I might I who knows well
this is going to air after January 1st
so let's see if when this drops if
you're still good you got to get out of
here brother thank you thank you for
taking a trip down I got give flowers
everything you do is so thoughtful and
our business and I'll speak for myself
sometimes when you you do stuff with
each other there things on a calendar
and you go in and you go I'm going to
I'm I can say someone I love but I'm
going to do Whitney's podcast and you go
okay Whitney's a little different it's
she puts as much thought as you do but
sometimes you go do podcasts and you
it's just a thing in the calendar you
know you got to do and you're like well
I got to [__] think of a cool story I
don't have to think of anything when I
work with you you put th so much thought
into the products you make these
podcasts that they are a true joy and I
end up finding myself coming out
fulfilled like feeling richer for the
experience and I have to say this and if
please clip this out if you're not
listening to Ryan behind a mic talking
to anybody you're missing the joy of
podcasting
you have done this better than all of us
and you do it at such a [__] high
level your interviews with people I I
see things of guys I've known forever
Felipe I know Felipe very well but when
he I hear you talk to him I learn so
much more about our friends that I just
don't I I don't know and don't and and
I'm telling you I would do this with you
every single day if Tom dies
I I would love for me and you to just
take over two bears
well thank you for real you don't
understand how much that means to me
coming from guys like you and Tom and
you've helped so much oh you've inspired
this I mean this is my little mini
version of what you got going on thank
you dude thank you for I'm so glad
you're health I'm so glad I love you
dude I love I love having friends like
you I I'm a richer man because of that
same thank you brother I love you bur I
love you more uh as always Ryan sickler
docomond sickler on all social media we
will talk to y'all next
[Music]
week